je suis arrivé à l'om en novembre 1989
et mon premier match joué avec l'om a
été au stade de la beaujoire contre le
fc nantes le 25 novembre 1989
quand même trainer et aucune dépense
c'est psychologique
quand on est joueur on est acteur il ya
la dépense physique quand on se donne le
meilleur de soi n'est sur le terrain
magnifique footballeur c'est le plus
beau métier demi
11 ans j'étais déjà bien développé je
faisais déjà en m 62 72 73 donc j'ai
franchi les étapes un peu plus vite
j'ai fait mon la première apparition en
donnant en ligue 1 j'avais pas j'avais
pas encore 17 ans je me sentais bien
c'était une famille mais j'avais un
manque viscérale qui me faisait parce
que je me rendais compte que non et est
toujours un bon club mais qu'on était
plus armé pour gagner et je souffrais de
ça me rappelle robert budzynski qui
m'avait dit je me rappelle d'un match de
toit où il faisait un temps exécrable un
terrain boueux et il y en avait qu'un
qui courait comme un malade et qui avait
le caractère qui qui se battait sur tous
et tais toi
j'ai toujours eu ça en moi quand je
jouais je perdais gitex écrin je
supportais pas ça mais bon j'ai eu la
sollicitation mais de l'olympique de
marseille en cours de saison
mais à l'époque c'était le plus gros
transfert français
l'arrivée à marseille en cours de saison
déjà c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose d'évident
j'étais jeune j'avais peine un peu plus
de vingt ans je fais me donald je
pensais sur sur une autre planète quoi
déjà quand je me rappelle quand je suis
arrivée à l'aéroport de marignane et les
photographes journalistes de partout
c'était l'obligation de gagner c'était
être champion de france
la coupe des champions à l'époque jeunes
comme ça
maîtrisez l'environnement les exigences
j'ai eu une période de moins bien je
suis arrivé au mois novembre les juges
comme la trêve hivernale s'est si bien
passé après en janvier j'étais moins
bien moins à l'aise - libéré
arrive avec cette demi finale face à
benfica
c'est la dernière étape pour pour
arriver
à la finale on a un premier match à
domicile face à une équipe de benfica y
avait beaucoup de brésiliens notamment
val de cadeaux on peut brossé tracé en
grosse effervescence sur ce match
c'était compliqué pour moi parce qu'on
m'avait donné une attache particulière
très sympathique ce que j'étais un
marquage individuel sur valdo qui était
leur meilleur jour alors c'est quelque
chose que j'aimais pas faire mais
c'était mon boulot on m'avait même dit
peu importe si tu joues pas l'essentiel
ce que je joue à 10 dans le sens où si
on voit pas mal d'eau c'est mieux même
si on te voit pas toi bonjour à dix
contre dix et connaissant valdo qui
bougeait un peu partout compliqué très
technique je les fais parce qu'on me l'a
demandé mais je dirais un peu à
contrecoeur je dirais pas cette solution
là donc bon j'ai eu un match difficile
et en plus dans le même match voilà je
me retrouve être sur les corners au
poteau 2e poteau
j'avais horreur de ça aussi mais bon
comme je faisais pas partie des plus
grands jetés là mais je savais pas quoi
je servais je savais pas où me
positionner j'aimais pas je n'ai passé
et d'ailleurs ça s'est vérifié parce que
malheureusement on prend on prend un but
là dessus ou au bon je suis pas bien me
positionner il ya un corner une tête et
je suis si j'aime positionnement juste
je peux je peux être plus influents et
peut-être empêcher de prendre
de prendre ce
ce but là
si je me rappelle bien on avait quand
même gagné le match 3 2 1 au match aller
ce qui me laissait une petite marge mais
on savait que la base c'est à dire de la
luz ce retour ça allait être compliqué
parce que bon il y avait 100 110 mio chf
soit 110 ou 120 un vacarme est
ahurissant
même à 10 15 mai on ne s'entendait pas
sur le terrain
match solide mais malheureusement il y a
il a de nouveau ce corner
sept minutes de la fin on appelle chez
poteau dont je vois bien il
l'époque est au marquage qui ceinturent
vatin et qui a
voilà le fait de le ceinturer il a voulu
se dégager
et marque certes de la main
énorme énorme déception parce qu'on est
passé à côté d'une finale de
de champions league sortez la première
pour marseille et là on s'arrête
didier deschamps on va faire ça
l'entraîneur jean tigana à la place de
tigana fait une deuxième partie de
saison moins bonne et c'est pour ça que
l'om avait pris la décision de ne prêter
à bordeaux en partant là bas mon idée
c'était de revenir même posé à marseille
parce que j'avais signé à marseille et
j'ai vidé connu une bonne période au
colloque plus difficile je savais
pourquoi parce que j'arrivais pas à
passer par dessus à me libérer c'est
vrai que le personnage tapis aussi même
pression' et j'avais du mal à
communiquer avec lui alors au bout d'un
an à bordeaux qui s'est plutôt bien
placé voilà j'ai été confronté à un
problème aussi c'est que le club des
girondins a été rétrogradé donc pour moi
c'était inconcevable de d'être en
deuxième division et là j'ai discussions
avec bernard tapie qui veut m'envoyer à
paris un échange de deux joueurs et je
lui dis non non le risque il est
clairement tapis mais je les ai eu deux
fois au téléphone ml et me dit mais tu
tues tu vas être avec la réserve tu ne
joueras pas du tout en fait tout pour me
décourager ces arguments là
voilà way
ça ta carrière c'est trop compliqué pour
toi tu y arriveras pas pour moi l'om est
venu me chercher il fallait que je me
pose dans ce club là et puis j'avais
l'année à bordeaux on m'a permis de
prendre encore plus confiance de gagner
en maturité
je me sentais prêt à affronter de
nouveau le contexte marseillais qui est
très difficile très exigeant pour moi il
fallait que je me pense dans ce club
je vous rappelle aussi le premier
deuxième match où l'on retrouve 14e pas
sur la feuille de match parce qu'elle
est en paix avec eux que 13 joueurs là
j'ai pris un coup sur la tête j'ai dit
oh là ça va être compliqué mais on m'a
donné ma chance ça qui m'a donné ma
chance
l'entraîneur aussi du chômage du psg ou
à voilà j'ai eu une discussion
évidemment avec l'entraîneur mais avec
lui aussi mairie et libère-toi lâche toi
tu as le potentiel et l'abstraction un
peu de tout et puis c'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai franchi locale j'avais fait un
très bon match et à partir de là sur
l'euphorie de la confiance j'ai pu
enchaîner je suis sorti 2
une très belle saison pour moi avec
comme point noir c'était cette
élimination qu'entre prague
mais sur un plan individuel voilà où je
m'étais bien imposer aux militaires et
j'allais pas avoir les mêmes
incertitudes ou les mêmes discussions
pendant l'intersaison
leur match avait jeté jean luc ettori
d'un but à monaco
eric et ou il arrêtait tout donc il a
fallu que je mette une frappe
surpuissante de 35 m non je rigole quand
je dis sur personne il ya eu du mistral
ce jour là le ballon à fuser un petit
peu c'est certainement pas la frappe la
plus difficile qu'il a eu à réaliser
et didier deschamps clair que ça va être
incroyable
cette occasion
quoi c'est pas du tout
pour lâcher son vélo
marseille gagne 1 0 à domicile but de
deschamps là il ya du mal de fait leur
nom mais ça fait plaisir c'est que j'ai
pas marqué beaucoup de buts décisifs qui
a des dépôts monique quelques autres
quand même mr ouai c'est un très bon
souvenir
certains n'est pas ce que je frappe de
si loin
il y avait déjà un cadre qui avaient une
expérience de bari 90 91
pour en avoir parlé un peu avec ce
qu'ils avaient vu que ça et il avait
fait le match avoir dans leur tête ils
avaient consommé énormément d'énergie
avant même d'avoir joué le match dangla
c'était tout à fait l' inverse on se
retrouvait assez loin de munich
on était dans un hôtel mais super
convivial quoi je me rappelle il y avait
même la presse qui étaient là même le le
jeu crocs et le matin du match n'était
la fenêtre enfin faire tomber des seaux
d'eau sur les sur les gens mais le
groupe y vivent est vraiment hyper bien
on été relâché concentré mais mais
décontracté le jour de la finale c'est
un peu plus crispé je dirais un peu plus
tendu un peu plus de concentration
on était
confiant évidemment mais ont rencontré
le top niveau
c'est le milan séance le grand club avec
évidemment de très grands joueurs dont
van basten reich quarts de mon état
sautille until au type et jean pierre
papin aussi quand on rentre tunnel là
pour aller au vestiaire
sauf on regarde à gauche pour le même
gabarit quoi à ça et des belles bêtes
il y avait chez pas isolé au moins huit
8 ou 9 joueurs plus d'un mètre 85 m 90
kg impressionne quand même un gros souci
qui l'ambiance au stade quand on est
arrivés fabuleux avec
à moitié du stade pour marseille à
moitié pour pour le moment c'est un truc
qui donne les frissons et la
l'échauffement j'avais vraiment de très
bonnes sensations je suis je sentais que
j'allais plus vite que je soutiens plus
haut que je des fois mais l'adrénaline
je m'arrive quelquefois d'avoir ce à
quoi malheureusement cette sensation à
s'arrêter très vite je sais pas comment
ni pourquoi je vous de cinq minutes de
jeu
comme si on avait coupé les jambes
pas de juan terrible terrible là je sais
que voilà que je vais devoir faire la
finale à ne pouvons pas être comme je
l'aurais imaginé ou souhaitez quoi juste
j'ai combien de fois dans ma tête j'ai
dit mais pourquoi pourquoi aujourd'hui
finale de champions league pourquoi
pourquoi je sais pas je suis pas bien
pourquoi j'essaie ses jambes qui
répondait pas donc match pénible mais
bon
on a une entame catastrophique si on n'a
pas ça va bien dans le but
sur les 20 premières minutes ils ont
deux trois occasions c'est lui qui nous
qui nous maintient à flot
puis à ce corner et puis bon voilà juste
avant la mi-temps quoi basile qui marque
de son pied gauche
c'est bien je le pechoux présente à
chaque fois il a un pied gauche mon pied
droit magnifique frappe du fonds un peu
plus fort de la tête et qu'avec les pics
mais voit ses jours la voilà il est je
pars qui à la lutte avec riesch garde je
crois et puis bon voilà on rentre aux
vestiaires 1-0 ap à dire que c'est
mérité mais en maine et là il ya une
sensation d'un moins gelé je pense que
beaucoup de joueurs ils ont eu ce qu'ils
vont pas nous marquer deux buts qu'on a
fait le plus dur et on est convaincu
chacun que ça y est c'était notre jour
si nani mais d'une force à l'intérieur
la plupart pour pas dire à la totalité
que même si on allait souffrir ou quoi
que ce soit mais que ça y est la
boutique était fermé c'est le jour de
gloire
sa folie un peu partout tout le monde
s'embrasse la joie c'est fabuleux
quoique voilà garder tous avant ce match
on s'est dit qu'elle est à 12
dynamo
longuet deschamps est ce que vous avez
ressenti quelque chose qu'on dans ce
match est ce que vous étiez certain de
gagner la coupe euro
c'était un combat très dur et les
milanais ont raté quelques occasions au
début et puis nous on en a eu dans la
vie locale et après on a tenu et puis
tenu a réussi à tenir c'est ça qui
compte
didier je crois que au nom de toute la
france tout le monde vous dit merci
merci vigueur bon après y'a me la joue
un peu bizarre individuels comme j'étais
le capitaine je savais que j'allais être
le le premier à le lever la coupe
voilà c'est un peu le privilège mais
je me rappelle ce que m'avait dit
platini derrière qu'on puisse qu'il
était là bas il m'avait dit écoute prend
le temps de monter les marchés parce que
tu sais pas si c'est 3 l'occasion de les
remonter notre faim c'est vrai j'avais
jamais pris le temps de chaque pas pour
les jusqu'à ce qu'à lever la coupe
c'était
emotionnellement quelque chose de
fabuleux
qui a prévu le lendemain quand marieuse
monstrueux souci truc de folie folie
je me rappelle on arrive avec le bus ont
été escortés tout ça directement devait
présenter la coupe vélodrome et pour
n'arrive avenue du prado
mais c'est noir de monde aussi dit mais
qu'est ce qu'ils font là pourquoi ils
sont pas dedans s'était déjà plaint déjà
plaque un truc de fou de fou
on était sur une autre planète pour
marcher marcher sur l'eau en été sur les
nuages quelque chose de d'un descriptif
de le vivre de l'intérieur et voir ce
cette folie qui a embrasé marseille
s'échapper
mais mentionner allemand ça reste quand
même deux des plus grands moments de ma
carrière de joueur
et
c'est difficile de mettre de côté
l'aspect sentimental par rapport à ce
que l'om représentait pour moi et c'est
avait représenté pour moi en tant que
joueuse que l'om m'avait apporté en tant
que joueur il avait besoin de moi en
tant qu'entraîneur je savais où je
mettais les pieds avec des exigences
très élevées
l'équipe qui lorsque j'ai pris la
décision de dire oui elle était en lutte
pour le titre
j'ai une longue longue réflexion par
rapport à ça mais
mais je savais qu'il y avait la
possibilité aussi de jouer la gagne
d'aller vers cette culture de la gagne
aussi de se battre d'avoir les moyens de
se battre avec les meilleurs donc c'est
pour ça que c'est j'ai accepté ce
challenge
fini la première partie de saison
vraiment difficile on joue auxerre chez
nous le dernier match avant la trêve qui
peut nous faire basculer sur une bonne
première partie de championnat et qui en
match cauchemardesque perd 2 0
et puis là je suis sur mon bon là je me
dis on est dans le dur
puis j'ai eu voilà quelques
manifestations on a scandé le nom de mon
prédécesseur vraiment le tournant c'est
la demi finale contre toulouse
sincèrement si on élimine et là je pense
qu'on a une fin de championnat très
compliqué so lu ment tout seul entretien
j'ai pourtant éliminé à six minutes de
la fin brandao égalise
et puis marque un deuxième but dans les
prolongations et là ça se passe
j'en viens je crois et il ya l'objectif
d'une finale pendant deux mois la
cellule du pain blanc pour l'entraîneur
et tout mon staff je sais que les
joueurs ils vont penser à ça ils feront
tout pour être là cette finale et entre
temps le championnat oui l'enchaîner un
bordeaux connaît de grosses difficultés
et nous évidemment se rapprocher et puis
il ya l'autre grand moment mais oui
c'est ici voilà marseille avait joué le
contre temps quatre finales pour quatre
ou cinq tout perdu et puis là c'est
celui-là et et c'est bordeaux meilleur
adversaire que vous pouvez rencontrer et
cette victoire là
donner un boost incroyable pour la fin
de saison de voir les jeunes des
générations de supporters qui avaient
pas connu l'om qui gagne
las de voir des gens heureux même chez
les joueurs sont découverts même les
étrangers signe aussi une coupe de la
ligue et il ya ce seuil à st imaginez si
on est champion de france
donc ça a été quelque chose qui a été
vraiment un catalyseur qui a donné
encore plus d'énergie pour faire une fin
de saison en boulet de canon on a eu une
période on avait cinq matches en 14
jours
on a pris 15 points je suppose que ce
soit réalisable quand avec certainement
un peu de réussite aussi un peu de de
chance mais c'est là où bon on a basculé
du bon côté pour pour arriver à près à
ce ce match contre rennes puis cnc au
vélodrome est vrai que les champions
c'est toujours beau de l'être au
vélodrome donc ouais assez
grosse grosse satisfaction
émotionnellement la ligue c'est bien non
plus d'être champion de france après 17
ans de disette
évidemment c'est de la joie de bonheur
au cumin
oui
fierté pour moi aussi
ok symbolique d'avoir été
les derniers qu'ils aient gagné quelque
chose en tant que joueur est revenir en
tant qu'entraîneur après de longues
années pour un beau clin d'oeil et d'une
certaine manière c'est si avoir redonné
moi aussi à ce club tout ce qu'il a eu à
ma portée
mais mieux